well this won't stop us from digging a
bit deeper hanspeter book of joins us
now he's a professor of banking and
finance at the University of horn I'm
thank you very much for coming because
as a professor of course you have to
talk about this topic all the time even
now during the summer break I hope
you're not yet fed up with it well I am
fed up and I would love to talk about
something else but the point is the
crisis is still there we have to talk
about it and we have to serve it somehow
and this might last for long period of
pants though okay well somehow one gets
the feeling that our politicians at
least now right with the election coming
up are in some sort of denial do you
think this is the calm before the storm
I think to some degree it is and as it's
got to raise one obviously the electrons
on the other end government especially
term govern might be interesting to have
the financial crisis little bit mayor
more on the on the forefront because the
solution concepts of the Social
Democrats and greens Green Party I'm not
very persuading to the general public
but on the other hand I mean Draghi said
all this is psychological we have to
solve it on up psychological level so
it's very important not to disturb
anybody with anything we might know but
it might be well a bad news okay well
let's hope that the summer break will
last a bit longer if it's all about
psychology and because losses are there
exactly yeah especially and that we've
seen in our report as well many European
banks they're still harboring bad loans
on the balance sheets loans that could
soon fall through we prepared a little
graphic here for you now Deutsche Bank
for example has reduced its portfolio of
Portuguese Spanish and Italian bonds in
the last three years from 12 to five
billion euros commands Bank however
still holds bonds from crisis written
eurozone states worth 11 billion euros
how risky is the situation would you say
well it is not that risk in both legs
but the shells different degree of
freedom Deutsche Bank was able to get
out of these portfolios sometimes with
losses commerzbank was not able to go
out that easily because they have losses
from some Weld if you look at southern
European banks they gone the other way
around the increases their portfolio and
whiskey government debt because I say
well it's my country
and we're doing something good for
countries biases bonds and if our
country fails we'll fave is a country
anyway so it doesn't matter well let's
let's stick with those balance sheets
for a while I mean there have been
several stress tests for banks now what
have they achieved so far well not very
much well we should know the publishing
stresses our solution to everything if
you're a specialist in this topic you
know a stretch that is very is a very
rough instrument to find out about
something special scenario what happens
in this position are there are so many
different possibilities in the future so
I think this is not a good solution and
we found in many cases banks who pass
the stress test we're bankrupt very soon
afterwards do we have time for all this
though or do you agree we also heard a
reporter that the president of the
German banking supervisory board baffin
has urged the ECB to finally get down to
business do you agree with that well on
the other end she said take your time to
get things really done before we enter
the business we had a first try with our
European Banking Authority in London and
they utterly failed at the truth about
it and and now we must really let let
things go in where there's a function
and that will take a lot of time maybe
another two years but if its functions
and that's good enough then you're even
less optimistic then the president of
the bathroom you say two years time not
next year now once the ECB does get down
to business and starts supervising what
exactly can I do it should it do to
restore order well the idea is that it
should interfere in countries where the
national Banking Authority hasn't been
strong enough in the past problem is do
they have really right to enforce what
they decide and I'm afraid we were
talking about sovereign state still so
if for example to Greece government says
but we see this otherwise for Charlie
ECB do about it so I wonder what will
really happen if it's got really more
force than the national regulate hair
the fast in the past well I'd pick a
book off thank you very much for joining
us during the summer break